because you've never been to australia
it's too far
this was a chore for me this is the
first time i've worn underpants in a
year
australia's a long spider snakes
alligators crocodiles
jellyfish sharks sharks
because it is properly dangerous isn't
it i mean you
you suffer
you do you know yeah well they're not
your own legs
wombat
i got a very nasty spider bite
on a bush took a trial
um it was on mars is that your nickname
for it
it wasn't nasty it was a tiny little one
no no no i wasn't sure what it was it
was zombie hands oh wow and martina
navratilova's bush took a trial
and we were down there
a weird sentence you didn't evolve
and offering words of encouragement you
know you're doing great martina that's
one get it down here
we went back up to the production office
afterwards and i felt that
my hands swelling up a bit
a mouth spider it could have been it
could have been so then anyway the the i
went home that day and no
yeah really where did the next day i
went on that day i kept getting worse
woke up the next morning and it turned
into two
blood blisters on the side of my hand
and i saw them i was like oh my god and
i'm a bit queasy anyway at the best of
times so we got back into the production
office i need to see the medic i need to
see the medic so they sent the medic up
to the office and we have we have desks
which are opposite each other like this
and the medic so the medic comes in and
he says can i sit in your chair i'm
going to lean over i've got to give him
an injection so i was like yeah no
problem so i got up and i just left the
office shut the door
i thought i'd give him some privacy
it's been a while open the door he was
on his back with his
legs end
with an oxygen mask
and the medic was fun of them why i
passed out
with needles i had a needle oh really
not a spider bite
did you know it was a spider at the time
what did he tell you that did you fear
did you see a spider bite you no no no
no so he he told me he said that's
that's a spider bite
right
what spider mouth spider did you say a
mouth spider no they they get necrotic
and they come inside when it rains there
are so many things these are evil
they're evil there's so many things in
australia that can just kill you but by
looking at you you know all these little
tiny things and and and the australians
as well
yeah they don't hide in your toilet do
they are under your sink
australians make a great sport they have
grip take great pleasure in scaring
british people about
the the dangerousness of their animals
but still you want to go back there you
don't want us to it's almost certainly
spiritual okay fair enough
and also it's four weeks in australia in
november december night
[Music]